in five four three two one
what's up you cross-eyed [ __ ]
curly-haired suck faces welcome to
another episode of genius brain we are
shooting this in the morning because
we're getting [ __ ] done and we're here
to talk about stuff I am your co-host
David so and I am your other Coco
co-host
Joe Jitsu kala baby yo so uh my parents
I fool my parents inform a Sacramento oh
[ __ ] for your buck man
did I forget like I love my dad yeah
[ __ ] annoying here sometimes because
he has this very weird habit you know
like when you chill with somebody it's
okay for there to be like silences yeah
it's like for example this is this is an
appropriate time for there to be a
silence is when you're watching a
[ __ ] movie yeah you just kind of
watch and chill so we're watching [ __ ]
my dad has is very odd habit when we
watch stuff he always has to say
something and I think that the annoying
part about him having to say something
is that it doesn't even have anything to
do with the movie oh we were watching
the movie and then my dad out of nowhere
he goes toilet seats are interesting huh
what like what do you mean right he does
you know toilet seats are just sometimes
are cold when you sit on them and
sometimes are one look at my dad's I'm
like what are you saying like why are
you saying this right now right he's
just talking I'm like okay what the even
if even if that has something to do with
the movie why are you talking right now
like don't talk like just watch the book
so my mom gets so annoyed it was this
point there is no point you just wanted
to start a conversation in the middle of
the [ __ ] movie exactly like we're
watching this movie in my apartment and
then my mom just even my mom gets
annoyed so she goes okay she gets up she
walks into my room I just started
watching [ __ ] on her phone Wow she has
to deal with that 24/7 yeah are your
parents together all day every day all
the time that's why when I see cuz you
know as Barton geo they work really well
together
yeah and they had their own system but
even when they work together they're
still kind of working separately
yeah separate space they might be in the
same environment but they might not be
in the same meeting but yeah your
yeah they're doing something separate
yeah but even when I see that like I it
reminds me of my parents because I see
them working together side by side all
the [ __ ] time and I think that's why
they get into so many fights it's not so
much that they that they're they're so
different or they hate each other it's
more like if you see somebody's [ __ ]
face 24 hours a day seven days a [ __ ]
week you don't get a break from their
energy no yeah because they work at the
same business yeah and they have to look
at each other all of the [ __ ] time
damn so and they don't have the skills
in their mind to like yeah solve
conflict and then my mom we were in the
car at that same thing when we were in
the car going back back home my dad is
just talking talking talking and then my
mom just like my dad's is cracking up
seriously your mom has to hear this all
the time but you guys have to here even
knows even though he's doing this [ __ ]
so he's probably just got like a lot of
pent up [ __ ] going on and he's bored out
of his brain that's like he's kind of
like you know like if you leave a dog
home too long yeah and then you finally
take him out to walk he can't he wants
to smell everything Poole [ __ ] every
single dog every single person they're
just too much that's exactly what my dad
is dude dude it was so hard to deal with
and they're so innocent but the same
time is just I had to sit there and just
take it and I just don't understand it I
don't mind him talking but it just it's
at the most inappropriate times and the
subject matter doesn't make any sense so
I don't even know what to say like even
during the film he goes
my brother has a girlfriend and he knows
her [ __ ] name yeah he knows her
[ __ ] name right and he goes oh you
know Elizabeth and my brothers like why
did you why did you call it that right
he goes well I saw it on her Instagram
he goes yeah but that's her middle name
and you know that's her middle name so
why are you saying that right he goes oh
should I call her something different my
buddies like you just you just want to
talk this is the talk at this point like
just don't say anything like what does
he want to say little child yeah he's
like beating around the bush and he's
like oh you know toy let's see when you
gonna get married
yes he's trying to open up into that or
something yeah there's no there's no
point to the conversation so I don't
know where to take it so even if you're
out if you are talking it's like what am
i where is this conversation going dude
where where it's like we're in a boat he
just opens up a sail and he goes time
for adventure does he watch all your
stuff uh not my mom does but not much oh
yeah he watches this and he's like Shi
Bao that's not what it is a beady Myna
Parker I know exactly what I want to say
you don't have friends like to break up
that they do so they do have friends so
they just annoy each other or what's
going on you know what it is - my
parents don't have a lot of friends and
cuz you know my dad was a pastor so he's
a social human being but my dad's very
selective about the people that he keeps
because he's been [ __ ] over so much
yeah you know so like I think in our
lives like because he's a pastor and
he's so giving he created a decent
community but you know when you have
when you give so much yeah uux sometimes
like internally you expect somebody to
reciprocate that same type of love back
but a lot of the times for my dad's case
he got burned so much Dan he's an
innocent girl that got cheated on too
much and then she became a whole so my
dad [ __ ] all guys so that's why I like
even for me I become like highly
skeptical of people is because my dad
built that Amy because I've seen him you
[ __ ] over so ma yeah like I've
witnessed it
you know II mean so my dad we have like
a few friends but it's like friends no
he's kept since ever yeah like you know
Victor Kim oh yeah yeah yeah so Victor
Canada dancer the dancer from the quest
group yes yeah so Victor Kim his parents
and my parents have been friends since I
was a little kid in since Korea or like
no it's just America
so like when we were super I'm Tom uh
since I was like five or four years old
yes I've known Victor since we were
little little kids and so um they still
they're still friends till this day and
they had dinner like every other Sunday
there's like uh like Abe Abe's parents
like I call a my cousin only because
I've known as Saul like two years old
but there were friends before your
guys's birth or I think before my birth
yeah so it's been a long [ __ ] time
dude that's tight and so like my mom and
his mom are our best friends so they
talk on the phone a lot well that's
pretty good because
that's a great segue to the question of
the day so the other day I went on
Twitter and I asked like we're about to
go film huh
what's a good question right and I'm
like [ __ ] and I got this one right here
Emelia eight nine two four seven five
five that's a lot of numbers girl but
Amelia ass you guys have the best group
of friends tips on how to find the right
people and to get and to let go of the
bad ones I've been leaving people lately
and kind of have none or no one but
they've hurt me bad and they weren't
good friends is it better to be alone
for some years or should I go back
damn dude that's a deep one yeah oh [ __ ]
that opens up into a lot of things man
yeah but I mean it's it's crazy how it
just naturally kind of flowed into it
yeah yeah cuz um I think friends is like
it's so important right like we're
social creatures even if you're
introvert and you like being alone human
beings are such social creatures and
force a lot of people on their deathbed
or like they say you know you ask
seniors like what what's the number-one
thing you regret or like what would you
do differently in life and everyone's
like I would have spent more time with
friends and family oh yeah that's all
they talk about friends and family
that's what matters the most for human
beings yeah but like you know when we're
young it's like we think about our
career we think about you know our goals
our hobbies and everything else
everything else that doesn't really
matter you know we're not when I was
building friendships growing up you know
we talked about this I think like we I
think you and I were similar in the
sense of like we I think we could float
and mold to a lot of different groups
right yeah and so one of the things that
kind of messed up in that sense was whoa
here's a good thing about that is that I
got to pick and choose who I wanted to
be around with but sometimes I felt like
for me up to a certain point in high
school I kept on trying to mold who I
was to fit somebody else right so a lot
of the times when when people are young
they develop Frenchy's not so much on
how these people make me feel they want
acceptance yeah but it's more like how
these people will make me look like
these are these are the cool girls won't
be a part of the hot cool girls exactly
so like these are the guys that always
like the popular dudes I want to be in
that group because I'm one of them
because if you look at if you look at
the JK group all I feel like even even
the way things are are staffed and the
way people work in the company yeah
everybody is very very different but the
one thing that I think a lot of the
people have in this company is that
they're very true to their selves yeah
you know what I mean you know that
nobody in the company is there to to
kind of appease other people's and so
they still had their very own identity
and that's what I really connect with at
the end of the day and if they don't
they don't stick around very long very
true yeah that's that's I think you're
right about that because I always love
people when they are comfortable with
themselves cuz like it's like if you
know you're a nerd but you wear it with
a badge of honor and you love your geek
stuff and whatever then ii mean it's
like oh you're cool because you're
comfortable with yourself or like you
don't like the Wong foo guys you know I
always told them they are gay you know
the whole nice guy stuff like oh come on
man yeah but I mean what I loved about
them is that they wore it with a badge
of honor they're like yeah I'm a nice
guy like I'm a you know like I'm not
like these other guys like that's just
who I am and I'm like that's [ __ ]
awesome dude I love that about you yeah
we met a lot of people that are always
fronted I'm like come on man you're not
from the hood you're from somewhere else
but why do you speak that way yeah you
grew up around a bunch of white people
and then I don't know why you act like
that and then it's like come on man
you're not you're you're not who you say
you are we can see right through you
yeah [ __ ] that and those are the people
that I feel like we generally dislike ya
know just to go back to the Wong foo
guys like they grew up very different
from us yeah they grew up in a complete
different vironment even that content is
different right so even for me when I
first started off YouTube and I and I
looked at the long food stuff house like
this is wack not because of what it
looked like it's cuz it didn't resonate
no of course I mean it's not to me now I
respect them as artists like it's not
sure what it's not bad work the work is
great and I look and then and then the
first thing that I loved about them is
the strangers again video yeah it's also
that's something I can connect with
regardless of like you know taste yeah
it's just different taste yeah right
like it's like it's different it's like
some people prefer hamburgers over fur
or whatever yeah so in that sense I
agree
like whenever I for I was like man this
is not for me any and I think a lot of
people who like their content were you
know high school college girls and like
it was just a different group of people
yeah yeah but even then no matter how
different they are
I still resonate with them a lot you
know we we still [ __ ] with them heavy
you know what I mean yeah and to go back
to that there's also a couple of
youtubers that I know where they they're
also like in that Asian American crowd
like every time I look at them I just
want slap the [ __ ] [ __ ] just because
just because they're not comfortable in
their own skin yeah and every time like
I've had a conversation with them
they always try to be something that
they're not yeah people can sense that
yeah you know like like if you're if
you're the dweeb just be the [ __ ]
dweeb and then I can connect with that
you know I'll find some kind of common
ground to spark a conversation to be
your friend yeah but if you don't know
who you are if you're constantly
bouncing around from different
identities then that shows me that I
can't trust you I don't trust you for
[ __ ] yeah you know it's like some people
go through this and junior high in high
school and then they figure it out yeah
but some people they don't get a chance
to do this until they're older like um
you know like I I had a friend who was
like I made this friend like after
college right and he he was I think he
was always like kind of like a geeky
dude but then like he finally was able
to be cool with everybody because of his
skills in film yeah and then like he
would keep bragging around us about like
how he was in the fried and he was in
this and all that and I'm all like I
don't care what your history was I don't
you know you don't to me it felt like
they were he was trying to like always
be like cam one of you guys I'm like I
don't care I'm fascinated about
something that's different in a writ
like that's unique to you you know but I
I know you're lying
yeah that's what I don't like it's like
stop [ __ ] exaggerating and lie
because you're you're just completely
you're a fraud yeah like you're not
being real with me I mean if you were a
part of band and if you're a part of
these things like tell me what that was
like yes it's not like I'm gonna be loud
you're a [ __ ] bang geek bro like what
ya look like Bart was a bangy yeah yeah
there's this kid when I went to UCR so
there was um two kids one guy there's
there's two Andy's that were so [ __ ]
weird
there was Korean Andy and then there was
[ __ ] Chinese Andy right so don't name
your kid and II am NOT a nerd kid Andy
and Andy out there mm-hmm
but uh Andy this is his name was spelt
and died right a nd ie I kid you not
that was how you spelled his [ __ ] and
the only way that I could differentiate
them without skal and I and and I would
specifically do that he hated that [ __ ]
but he used to [ __ ] annoy me because
he was like one of those dudes like and
died yeah let me tell you how [ __ ]
phony this guy is right number one when
I came to that school I never acted like
I was a thug right but I guess like when
they when people hear you speak they
they kind of assume what you are yeah
but mind you like if you just looked at
me right
are you [ __ ] good we need glasses and
you know that you would never think but
this guy every time he sounds like
that's like when people don't really
have any black friends and then they
finally hang out around black people
they start they try to go extra-urban
and [ __ ] yo yo yo I'm like it's so crazy
man so the funny thing about college is
what you can do in college in which
you'll find out if you're not in college
it you will always find these people and
you'll sniff them out they'll they when
they go to a university they go okay
nobody knows me here I'm gonna create my
own identity yeah and this is what this
guy was trying to do yeah they try to
start fresh
yeah so this [ __ ] right he was
by definition and I don't know talking
about a geek in terms of like what he
likes I'm talking about geek as in he is
so cringy he was so [ __ ] cringy dude
he showed up I kid you not when I first
met him he is like he looked up a video
about how to walk like a thug and if you
try to imitate it you know I mean it
looked like he had a broken leg yeah I
cannot make this [ __ ] up so he's walking
around like you know just kind of like
yo yo yo yo and then he wore this black
wife beater oh my god I like these baggy
pants which at the time weren't even in
yes I'm like yo what the [ __ ] is this
fool doing to them and he's like stars
like yeah man yeah what's up man yeah I
got some homies does like yeah I'm hard
to blah blah blah like Edward I'm
sitting there just just dying on the
inside like what is this guy [ __ ]
during college you fool he's exactly
he's in a university that's the whole
point of this [ __ ] so my last straw was
this so there was this dude and called
his name was James and this guy was a
klepto he he likes stealing love
stealing and mind you he's a rich kid
like it's from he's from from Diamond
Bar he lives in the country that [ __ ]
secluded like a dairy that's where like
snoop lives a [ __ ] yeah guys mad rich
but he's a klepto loves to steal we used
to go to a Food For Less to get all of
our [ __ ] yeah I'm somebody he's so good
at stealing that I didn't know how to
steal [ __ ] until I saw him I've never
really stolen stuff but he would steal
stuff so well because he would take
things as if it was already his yeah
that's what it was like you gotta steal
yeah it just doesn't look like he's
stealing it yeah you can't be like exact
he just walks in yeah and so for him
what he would do is he would steal his
hungry man dinners and so we will put
that in our dorm fridges right [ __ ] like
he's poor he's rich though I'm dying
he's bawling it's like he's a lad and he
needs a Apple and [ __ ] is he stealing
food no I'm talking about he's so
[ __ ] rich when we went to his place
out in Diamond Bar like his place looks
like a [ __ ] castle he had a tennis
court in the back and I think like it
looked like a helicopter landing pad I
think I'm exaggerating it right now but
that's what it looked like to me and
back in the day he had like a 50-inch
plasma TV and that [ __ ] was like 10
grand Wow he's like in 2005 yeah so he
had that on as well that's how ball it
is and mind you he's 18 at this point
but anyways he's stealing some [ __ ]
right he stole for the thrill yeah so
just the hungry man dinners stole it and
so when we went back to the dorm were
like yo we got to put this in all of
everybody's fridges just giving it to
everybody in the dorm yeah we'll just
put it in their fridges and they'll be
cool with the hair just take it anyway
that's free so this dude and he comes up
right i [ __ ] [ __ ] you not walks up to
you goes eh so this this dude his name
is Rishi okay
can I talk to you it goes Rishi yo man
y'all have been into some [ __ ] so uh I
can't have these hungry man dinners in
my fridge cuz you know that because the
Popo might come after [ __ ] crazy just
talking about this I completely forgot
about this guy he goes yo so I did you
take the hungry my dinners out because I
might get into some [ __ ] you know the
COS be looking after me they got my
phone tapped oh my god I'm not even
[ __ ] [ __ ] you dude and I got so
feel under surveillance and the hungry
man dinners might put him in a jail dude
I got so [ __ ] mad like I had at that
best point oh look I should I looked at
this dude and I said dude what the [ __ ]
are you talking about man what is the
cops gonna [ __ ] fly through the
[ __ ] window and scream watch the
hungry man dinners nobody gives a [ __ ]
dude I was so mad it's because he's such
a thug yeah tell that he feels guilty
he's afraid
yep he doesn't want to be caught with
stolen goods so I'm hungry man dinners I
know and like so you know how innocent
he is dude Crowley was getting anxiety
like oh my god not the cells berries
after at that point I just took my
[ __ ] with the guy cuz he irritated me
so much it was like dude this is not
working for you just be yourself so I'm
gonna kept it going that's hilarious ha
I just I thought was the last straw
under investigation
from what up man I got my phone tapped
man [ __ ] I'm a secret agent
you know like I got oh I got this bubble
gum thing I'm got going on you know it's
you know I got a I've been stealing
winter fresh you guys are saying like
when I write a lot of these scripts
mm-hmm and you see these weird
characters that pop up is literally
these type of human beings that I meet I
belong funnier than the truth if there's
nothing funnier like it almost sounds so
made-up but I can't even make [ __ ] up
like this so there's even the Kim
jong-il character if you guys remember
that kid that is based off of a real
human being that I've met number one is
based off my uncle who's a weirdo yeah
and number two is also the other Andy in
the college dorm that I'm
yeah and that's who I based these
characters off of yeah but these people
nobody [ __ ] with them because they just
couldn't be themselves right they just
really cut it and some people - they're
so good at hiding it that a lot of
people buy into it yeah there's another
I mean I've been fooled many times
yeah it's likable people yeah I mean
sometimes things are too perfect but you
just can't accept that something might
be wrong with this dude because you like
being around them and hanging out like
even in relationships right I mean guys
and girls get manipulated all the time
yeah from like it's like it's like it's
like nice guys like sometimes there's
genuine nice guys but there's like those
weird ones that are like they actually
want to bone the crap out of this girl
yeah but then they're pretending to be
the friend the Churchill Bunyan yeah but
they're not honest with their feelings
and [ __ ] and then but they don't want to
let go of that like closeness with them
yeah yeah yeah well they you know guys
also do that just because they're afraid
of rejection like they they could always
just say oh I was just trying to be a
friend yeah but that's manipulation yeah
for sure not it's not and then they
don't know that they're doing it but I
think a lot of these guys - they don't
know that
how fraudulent they are yeah I think
they just really want to be something so
I hate that term like fake it till you
make it cuz a lot of people misinterpret
what that means oh that's what I like
they're gonna dress the part they're
gonna act the part because they want to
be accepted as this image of who they
want to be it's pretty complex if you
think about it yeah it's like it's like
a person who is like let's say they have
low confidence right but they like I'm
in college now imma start fresh like I
used to be bullied all the time in high
school but now I'm gonna change things
so now I'm gonna be like super confident
and I'm gonna be different and that's
cool and all but there's a fine line
between like challenging yourself and
being a fraud and I think the people
that don't understand the difference
they become frauds because they do
shortcuts mmm and like you know for that
kid and I you know if you're listening
to this dude you were [ __ ] weird what
you could have done
conversely was not pretend to be a thug
you could've just been confident in who
you are the dweeb and he has a really
smart guy yeah you know you could have
just been confident in that human being
and mind you in our dorm
there were it's there was a lot of like
dweeby dudes but they were so dope
because they just were open about who
they were and that was that was the cool
part was their confidence and that was
the difference man I got a homie hit me
up recently his name is Tony
I grew up in gardena just like you but
he was like he was like a magnet school
student but and he never pretended like
to be a fella but he was such to me he
was such a cool dude just because I
could connect with him so well because
he was always honest with himself now
mind you he was also weird but a weird
type of way that I like yeah yeah I mean
like he was so [ __ ] weird this guy so
we were door mates and then one day he
told me to come into the bathroom he
goes hey David can you check out my pee
real quick and I was like all right
we're always on like I'll check out your
pee
he goes yo is that a normal color bro
I'm talking about his pee was pure brown
what does he not drink water so check
this out I go yo you're dehydrated yeah
right and he has migraines all the time
like yeah yeah and that's dehydration
right there I was like you're dehydrated
why was your pee so Brown right I was
like when's the last time you drink
water he goes I don't drink water okay I
don't drink water yeah that's the
peasants yo Tony I'm like you don't
drink water he goes yeah I'm thinking
about giving up a soda for Lent
so I could drink more water I was like
wait you you mean you don't drink water
a lot he goes no I don't drink water he
hasn't drank water since he was a kid
and he only drinks soda I'm surprised
he's not diabetic yo that's what I'm
saying well he had gout before and [ __ ]
too but oh [ __ ] yeah and it wasn't
really fat either so he only drank soda
specifically cactus cooler he got me in
the cactus cooler Joe no no no cool it
really it didn't have cactus Coola at
that time that's such an elementary
drunk right yeah so he was like yo do
you know Wendy what do you know about
Catholic school and I was like yo what
the [ __ ] is Jack it's cooler I had that
[ __ ] one of the one of my favorite sodas
on earth then they had no idea but he
only drank cactus cooler and I think it
was a squirt or some [ __ ] like that oh
he's one of those guys yes so for Lent
he gave up soda and in the first two
weeks I kid you not he could barely make
it to school because of the migraines he
was having from withdrawal Oh
yeah and I have so he he said that when
he drank water
it tasted like he was drinking like
liquid metal Oh cuz it's disgusting to
him yeah a slice and tastes like sugar
and yeah and so that dude he was so
[ __ ] weird but I [ __ ] with them hot
yeah it's never drink water before yeah
but I mean that's that's because of the
type of people we are yeah like we're
actually we have a lot of eclectic
friends yeah I think the normal world
out there is very judgmental very
uncomfortable very political like I uh I
mean it's difficult like a lot of you
know like if if we you know we're
comfortable with ourselves right yeah
but if imagine being self-conscious
again and worried about the opinions of
other people how they judge you right I
think that becomes a real threat for
most people so when you're out there
trying to make friends it's like you
feel like you're weird and different and
you just want people to accept you I
think that's what a lot of people go
through so for them it's hard to make
friends where I had to think about this
a lot because like it comes natural to
me
yeah like if I want to talk to someone I
talked to someone I don't give a [ __ ]
what they think you're my entertainment
and if I like you I choose to be your
friend or not right like that's how I
think social people kind of think mmm if
your social you're just like opening
your mouth and just like killing time
and I'm not these thoughts don't even
like happen in my head if there's no
game plan you know it just not happen
and then it you become natural at doing
it because we've done it for so many
years but I had to think about it a lot
because jess is actually very um like
introverted well in a way where she's
like she's very selective with their
friends you know she has like a handful
of homegirls that she spent you know
years being close with and then what I
noticed was like oh [ __ ] we're like
almost the opposite like she can be
business is what I call it like most
people they have to be business right
like when you go to the workplace or
when you go shopping everybody has this
like kind of role that they're playing
yeah
they don't show their real self I mean
she's real
she does in front but I think just by
over the years talking to and I was like
oh [ __ ] this is what a lot of our fans
go through yeah is you know they they
don't know if people accept him they
don't know if they trust people they
don't there's just a lot of like
uncertainty yeah that goes in through
their minds so I think like they can't
easily make friends and they once people
get burned it's like a bad breakup you
get your heart broke in you don't want
to try again all this stuff happens but
to me humans have always been
entertainment and I've been [ __ ] over
mm-hmm but I kind of like oh well you
know like I've always had a lot of close
friends so if I lose one I'm like I got
ten more not that that one wasn't
important but I always kind of had this
I guess defense mechanism in my head
that like kind of like well that sucked
and then I move on mmm but then I
learned from it like there are times I
think the younger I was it was like it
burned me and I stuck on and I was like
I can't believe I got [ __ ] over and
all that but then like how much time I
spent on being feeling [ __ ] over has
changed over the years and then after a
while you just get used to it it's like
being rejected a lot like in the very
beginning you talk to girls and then she
rejects you and in your heartbroken you
don't want to try we keep trying and
trying and trying and if a girl tells
you no it's like okay you know like so
what it doesn't make me a shitty person
or whatever we're to get into this quick
little sponsored ad real quick so uh
let's dive into that can I tell you guys
something can I tell you what this
genius brain podcast is brought to you
by I think it's Skillshare multiple
notes for no damn reason so if you guys
don't know what Skillshare is Skillshare
is an online learning community for
creators with more than 25,000 classes
in design business and more you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity creativity and career so
basically what I'm saying is that if you
have a new passion out there you have a
side hustle that you want to start or
begin this is a great way to go at it
sher basically gives you that knowledge
at your [ __ ] finger tips my
friends so for me the classes that I'm
taking right now specifically have to do
with photography because photography is
something that I like to do on the side
and because I did it through an
apprenticeship back in the day there's a
lot of I guess you could say like
fundamental basics that I don't know and
going through these courses helped me
out and it kind of adheres to the way
that I like to learn which is on my own
time so a lot of the times when you go
through traditional courses or classes
sometimes it's a little derived and it
doesn't teach you the things that you
want to learn what was skills sure it
has like your own library and you could
you know fast forward or rewind or learn
however the hell you want so that's why
I [ __ ] with Skillshare a lot so remember
people join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for my
listeners you get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering genius brain
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash brain
again go to Skillshare comm slash brain
to start your two months now that is
Skillshare comm slash brain when you
guys are on there let me know the
courses that you're taking if you like
it
let me know in the comments below
because you know what I [ __ ] with it
I'm using it and trust me people my
photo skills is getting up there skill
Shea you know and also like I think just
to go back to that gross question it's
like you're saying you're you're cutting
people out and you're the people you're
not getting close to these people
anymore you're finding new people you
find yourself being alone sometimes as
you get older you find out that people
either grow with you or the girl without
you yeah that's it yeah that's so true
we lost a lot of friends you know and
sometimes like you know the people that
you heavily [ __ ] with they just you just
grow to be different people and that
happens all the time and it's okay you
know it's not it's not a knock on them
it's not a knock on yourself either it's
just more like oh [ __ ] I guess we don't
have as much as in common as we used to
yeah so for example you know you know
probably for us like the people that we
[ __ ] with a lot we were doing a lot of
dumb [ __ ] together yeah once we stopped
doing that dumb [ __ ] that was the only
thing that was really connecting
yeah we didn't really have the same
values we didn't really value education
the same we didn't value business money
family the same it was like oh I just
like doing dumb [ __ ] with you but now
that I'm not doing it we have nothing to
talk about we have nothing in common
yeah that's true and so for her or him
maybe that was the case Amelia right so
her maybe that was the case for you or
or on top of that and you find yourself
being alone right now well that's okay
yeah you know you some people just have
to be okay with being alone yeah and for
me too
I I think in like in high school even
when I did hang out and I was floating
between all these groups sometimes it
felt like I was alone because I wasn't
comfortable with who I was yeah you know
and now we don't know who you want to be
around yeah because I think the worst
thing to do is hold on to shitty friends
mm-hmm if you know in your heart that
like you you hang out in this group and
you don't feel right there's a lot of
toxic [ __ ] going on like people talking
behind each other's backs doing shady
stuff like just you don't see a future
like a like sometimes you'll be the only
friend in a group of friends that want
to elevate that want to become better
and then but your friends don't right
this happens all the time I had a group
of friends that all they wanted to do
was drink every weekend and and they'll
be like yeah let's get together do
business and then the business meeting
will turn into a drink fest you know and
that made me feel like [ __ ] dude I
wanted I want to do something I want to
do something else or like even a hobby
like you might want to pick up a hobby
you want to tell your friends let's go
work out together and they don't want to
do it and you could only try so hard
till you got to go find a new set of
friends mm-hmm back then it was
difficult to do but now with online like
you can do it but I also think like
sometimes people think their friends are
shitty or think something's wrong but
it's usually them oh yeah there's that
too but in the very beginning I think
people have to figure out like what is
going on like why don't you like a group
of friends like what did they do
something like when people go all they
did me wrong it's like what do you mean
they did you
oh they they criticize my dreams and I'm
like man that's stupid like really did
you wrong is like what did they do like
do they steal from you you know did they
spread a rumor behind your back like are
they really violating trust like that's
that's really [ __ ] up most other
things it's just a misunderstanding and
you just don't communicate yeah because
there could be certain cases - for
example like we're giving you this
advice and you could only tell be
telling us you're only telling us
literally 1% of the story yeah there's
no one overall rule right yeah and so
for listen let's just use that example
for a case right so let's say somebody
goes well I'm leaving this group of
friends because they always [ __ ] on my
dreams and because they [ __ ] on my
dreams I'm not going anywhere so I gotta
leave these people well hold on for a
second well let's see your habits right
what if in that scenario you're actually
the [ __ ] up you keep saying your do it
you're gonna do something and you never
ever ever try it or accomplish it yes
you're lazy and you're a piece of [ __ ]
and they're just laughing at you because
you're all talk yeah cuz you're wasting
their time yeah and they feel like
you're lying to them yeah that can
happen too I've seen it both ways where
there there's actually a good group of
friends but there's one friend thinks
that everybody is against them when in
reality they're just trying to set them
straight like men quit [ __ ] up it's
like oh you don't believe in magic
shut up dude I mean there's cases like
that but there's also cases where you
know there's there's that person that
always gets stepped on because they're
so accommodating to everybody and it's
like you got to leave that shitty group
of friends man those people are [ __ ]
toxic yeah dude this I'm with this girl
she's not she's not like that but it's
kind of like she's so [ __ ] nice in
our group where you ever hang out with
people and this is back in the day when
we don't have we didn't have like a
stable job or a lot of money and when we
go out to eat there's seven people out
there but for some reason when everybody
puts in their money we're always short
like twenty or thirty bucks yeah right
so why the [ __ ] are we short twenty or
thirty dollars well this girl would be
that girl that would always just like
here's and she was just put in extra
fifty yeah and I think like that kind of
sucked because it it got to a point
where certain people in that group they
take advantage they got they took it as
they expected her to do that yeah you
know and I got
kind of sick of it it's a yo and I take
her side so yeah you got to stop doing
that yeah she goes all well we always
were always short it's like it's because
you keep enabling that type of habit and
allowing people to step over here she
started feeling a certain way about it
even before I had that conversation with
her she fleshy enjoy rest does she feel
like I'm I get to rescue them like maybe
there's a part of her that likes doing
it she's always just been that part that
she's always been hyper accommodating
yeah but I think that conversation had
to happen with her because she started
feeling like people were taking
advantage of her which they were yeah
but she was also enabling it so you
could say that until up to a certain
point but if you're also getting that
type of enjoyment of oh I'm bailing
these people out and then you keep doing
it without saying anything then you have
to take the responsibility of oh I'm
enabling this type of behavior so they
just expect it at a certain point yeah
you know so for her it was like you
gotta take a step back and say oh maybe
this is a little bit my fault as well
which maybe in this case I don't know
and once again we're just kind of
shooting the dark unless you give us
specifics yeah if you're losing all of
your friends it could be there's
something that you're misinterpreting
today it's her predating it
misinterpreting - I mean when people see
our friendship and everything the vlogs
and the happy times like they're getting
all the happy [ __ ] mm-hmm and they don't
get the pains that we went through as a
group yeah so um you know I don't want
to set up this false expectation but at
the end of the day it is entertainment
like we're not recording the drama that
we have within the group cuz that's just
not the kind of channel we are you're as
other vloggers might record that [ __ ]
but I think like when people look at
their humans right just relationship in
humans in general it's like they think
we're supposed to be happy 24/7 mmm they
think we're supposed to be like no
problems like oh you click so clicking
means it's effortless and I'm like I
think that's the worst thing that's
happened to humanity because you you
watch these movies of like perfect
romance and like perfect friendships and
and there's no problems and everything's
always positive and [ __ ] and I think
that's what [ __ ] people up because
you're supposed to be annoyed
at your family and your friends well
it's normal you spend enough time with
anybody you [ __ ] I bet you you annoy
yourself if you're alone and you think
all [ __ ] day you annoy yourself yeah
it's gonna be annoying and I think as
long as this human being has good
intentions genuine traits and I know
good intentions is subjective right
because everybody doesn't think that
they're shady even if there's being
shady they everybody thinks what they're
doing is right so like you have to put
into perspective like do you and your
values line up with them and that's all
you got to worry about and it's like can
you feel like you trust them yeah
and and it's like how do you find people
like that I think it only it's a skill
like that's why they call it social
skill right like it's not something that
you wake up one day and then it's like
oh I got it like like just the other day
we did this podcast with Mary oh and she
was talking about how she was so
innocent and sheltered that like she got
[ __ ] over a lot socially and those
things can burn people and make you
afraid to want to make friends right but
you know if you keep challenging
yourself what ends up happening is you
build this social skill and it's like
you become a hound dog you could sniff
out [ __ ] before it happens yeah but
if unless you go through this you won't
ever learn it and I think that becomes
something that holds people back or I
think that's also why like now
everyone's kind of more antisocial and
they like to stay home because when
you're dealing with people through text
or whatever it's not as harmful I guess
as like physically being there building
a relationship and and having a falling
out yeah when I dude I remember when
people were texting each other a lot
back in the day I used to hate texting
is the only call like I thought I
thought texting was dumb like I yeah she
had me when they disliked it people
would say hey what are you doing so well
just call me and ask and then we could
discuss it yeah but you know after a
while I guess I don't even know when
that switch happened where ice where I
preferred texting over call it's because
time is valuable man oh that's right as
we have
we have to contact like eight people
it's it's more efficient yeah that's
right yeah so I became an adult that's
why well you know what though like any
time when it comes to things that needs
more attention
I either pick up the phone or I meet
them face to face cuz like I've got into
a lot of miscommunicating texts like
especially when something serious right
whether it's business or anything else
you trying to explain yourself you can't
it's difficult to do it over text and
then you'll I think sometimes text
causes more problems relationships or
whatever so it's like if I got a sword
out in my head all right is this gonna
take more than a few sentences to
explain then I go hey let's talk later
yeah cuz I yeah I've been to so many
frustrating situations and then later
when we talk face-to-face is like oh
that's what you meant oh I meant it like
this yeah and you're like I hate that I
hate wasting time explaining myself five
times yeah I want to do it once and in
like because most fights I've recognized
comes with it happens because there's
not a clear line of communication you're
not understanding each other and and I'm
like what are the things that's holding
me back from understanding them one is
like maybe I don't know their tone when
they're when they're typing I don't know
what's on their face so I'm maybe I had
a stressful day so I'm reading that text
in a negative way thinking that they're
being negative yeah you know or like
there's just a lot of these small little
nuances that are very important in
communication that I'm like oh man if
this is a serious topic like you got to
do this face-to-face hear their thoughts
give them a chance to explain themselves
and then you can figure out like if you
can be cool and you can find a middle
ground yeah yeah yeah but I don't think
people do the work to try to fix [ __ ]
like it's always like I'm gonna win
because you hurt my feelings and I'm
gonna tell you how much you hurt my
feelings and you're wrong yeah that's
that's basically how people don't evolve
yeah it's it's it's just a weird thing
man like the human relationships are
something that really
a lot of time to curate and develop yeah
it's one of the hardest things on earth
yeah and when people say you know who
are you really closer you have so many
friends and I genuinely have more
acquaintances than I do have really good
friends I think that's the thing two
people don't know the difference of like
the levels of closeness hmm if you
notice that like a lot of people go all
you you you're tight with so many people
that's what they see or that's what they
things like I get along with a lot of
people but there's a difference right
like like I think if you're not socially
intelligent or socially versed like
people don't have layers of protection
mmm what I noticed is like like and this
is just coming from like talking to
people who are more introverted and less
social they're they're much more afraid
because they're actually more they're
more loving in a way like not to say
we're not loving people but they they
gave a lot of [ __ ] they give too much
love and they don't know how to
compartmentalize they don't know how to
like hey you only you only get like 25%
love because that's how much you deserve
but we'll work til that a hundred so
like there's got to be different levels
you know yeah yeah if you're a hundred
percent to everybody all the time then
you're gonna get hurt so you got to
learn like hey this now we earned 10% in
this relationship you know now it's 20%
you got to keep going in and it's not
like a test but it is because it's like
how much trust and and how vulnerable
can I be with this person you know you
take steps toward it but like a lot of
people that just want to give it a
hundred percent every time because
they're like I don't want to it's too
much thinking that's just like my that
kind of just perhaps back to my dad yeah
right same way I'm a hundred percent
every time 100% loving caring I think
that's the religious side of him but
when that burn happens when you give a
hundred percent yeah you get burned back
to hundred percent it hurts a lot yeah
more and that's yeah that's kind of
crazy because I definitely feel like
that's what happened to my dad and
that's what I would see a lot wrong yeah
and it made him into a person who isn't
he's not negative but it's more he's
very wary of people now
yeah because maybe in his case it should
be less wary of other people but more
cautious about how he handles his trust
yeah a lot because just because somebody
just because you do well by somebody
doesn't mean they'll do the same back to
you and that's kind of the lesson that
he learned yeah and that's just one of
those things that people have to learn
when they when they really do give out
of their heart yeah if you notice a lot
of our friends who claim they don't like
people or they're more anti-social there
are some of the most caring people in
the world yeah because they care so much
and they're so sensitive and then they
give so much to the people I think they
get jaded because they don't get that
same feeling a commitment that they want
to give and I'm like y'all too thirsty
man that's what I found out cuz I
thought I don't know antisocial people
just hated people and I'm like why yeah
what what's there to hate nothing
happened it's like oh that makes a lot
of [ __ ] sense it's cuz they're extra
sensitive they're extra like the
slightest thing goes wrong it hurts them
a lot for me it's just like oh it
bounces off and I'm like who are you to
me yeah yeah you said a few things but I
could still like you yeah that that
interpretation even when we say oh
that's a homie like that's a very loose
term you know it doesn't mean like I'm
gonna call this guy up to be at my
wedding or anything yeah I mean he's an
associate of mine it's all me yeah and I
have expectations like this person is
not gonna [ __ ] come to my rescue this
person is not gonna be there for me if
things are going you know sour in my
relationship but I like their company
yeah there's a difference between
enjoying someone's company and and their
my entertainment they're my they're my
like it's it's kind of [ __ ] up to say
they're minors entertain it but like in
most cases why are you make friends we
make friends to share a gang like a like
a hobby or like you like to get together
and you [ __ ] play basketball or
whatever right like and then and then
that might lead to like oh [ __ ] like we
both are into the same kind of girls and
then we talk about girls or whatever or
whatever
you know and there's different levels to
it right and then you start finding more
common ground and then you start caring
about each other and then you start
realizing that you both have maybe the
same goals or or you believe in the same
values and then you you're more
like-minded and you just enjoy each
other's company
and then there's different levels but I
think people don't know how to start
that level and they don't know you know
how to gauge what's right and you know
it's almost like like they go oh [ __ ] I
wait three days to call her or should I
like call her when I get our number yeah
you know like there's these different
things that people second-guess and
there's rules they don't know what the
rules are there's a lot of things that
kind of bleed into this to where it also
bleeds into people who say oh don't do
business with friends and this is where
it kind of gets a little confusing
because a lot of people who say oh this
is I started this business with a friend
they really weren't your friend though
no you were a homie and then you guys
discuss something and then you said you
know that'd be a great idea if we got
into this yeah and you didn't really
think about what your relationship is
with this person because if this person
was a friend friend like somebody really
tight then you should have known about
these habits that they've had yeah you
know I mean we didn't do anything
together projects wise until like three
years or something into our friendship
and that's because I think you know me
and you both are more like like we have
that mindset where sigh I don't want to
just jump into anything but that's not
to say that I don't trust you it's like
well let's see if something comes up
that's mutually beneficial you know but
you're right about this as I call don't
do friends don't do business with
friends and family it's like you guys
don't know each other
you guys got excited about the idea but
you didn't communicate and I think
that's the whole thing about friendship
right is like you can comfortably be
honest and communicate everything
without being judged yeah or even if you
do be judge even if you are judged
you're not unaccepted yeah like I could
say anything but I know that like we're
both accepting of each other yeah right
so like I have the type of comfortable
friendship with all of my friends slash
business partners or even if it's
written on a contract
if I have a different slap feeling about
it I could talk to them and I can be
like hey so this is how I feel I think I
[ __ ] up when I wrote this contract
there's how I feel today now I know by
law I'm bound to this but how do you
feel about it yeah and then I feel
comfortable that I could open up that
conversation with any of them and they
might disagree but I'm okay with that
you know like so that's what it's all
about is the ability to be okay with
just talking about everything yeah and
in making the friendship the priority
not the business or anything else that's
how you know like when they go oh you
know [ __ ] you should never do
business with friends it will ruin your
friendship
nah man your friendship was weak yeah
because the business or any other things
should never ruin a friendship yeah if
it was strong to begin with you know and
wouldn't you rather have your friendship
tested to see how dedicated they are I
would I don't want to waste 15 years
with someone just to know that I had a
like weak friendships cuz you a gambler
baby I like that
I always told people like I rather have
if if my girlfriend is gonna cheat on me
or my wife or whatever right like I
rather have them do it earlier than
later
yeah cuz if I spend so much more time
with them it's like that's what makes it
worse yeah yeah yeah I think also too we
we take personal responsibility for a
lot of the stuff that we do which I feel
from the people who aren't my close
friends they don't do that they don't
let's say like in a business thing like
something messed up that I proposed I'm
not gonna say oh [ __ ] well Joe you did
it how I'll be like oh [ __ ] my bad guys
you know and I take full responsibility
and then try to move on from it which is
something that's very important for me
in the essence cuz every time I've had a
bad business interactions because people
did not take personal responsibility
because their egos a month they don't
want to be wrong yeah yeah and you know
for me as a business partner I
I'll call things out not to shame you
say oh [ __ ] this is a problem in our
business let's fix it yeah I'm not
saying you're dumb it's just I'm not
gonna just let it slide by because I'm
worried about your [ __ ] feelings yeah
you know same for me you know so one of
the businesses that I had it's you know
I I fixed it from the ground up they
know you know we went from like a
business
making $50 a day - averaging about 25
grand a month yeah you know and it you
know that's what I did for it you know
at the end of the day when we had
business problems they they brought that
up they go well I feel like when you
bring things up like you always make you
feel like it's our fault and I'm like
hold on a second you probably talk to
them like they're idiots
yeah because it well what's what's the
problem then let me know it's like well
the other day you mentioned this this
and that and I was like that's not me
saying I have a problem with you I
looked at the numbers of the sales and I
said this this and this does it sells it
just turns out that you've made it it's
your thing cuz a lot of people take
things personally yeah and I think
that's why you can't have like business
and friends mix because if you're
friends the kind of person that that
like let's say doesn't like to be
challenged that doesn't like
confrontation that doesn't like to be
wrong then they're just not mature yeah
that's all it is it was such a weird
concept because when we had that meeting
and I remember this was a while back and
I and I took them I'll say okay cool so
if that's how you guys feel honest I'm
not mad about that like I want you guys
to be happy so if you feel bad about me
pointing out things that aren't doing
well in the sales and I don't want to
take it off the menu what what's the
solution and also - how about in this
meaning you guys bring up something that
I'm not doing right yeah and then we'll
fix it
dead silence it's cuz they don't know
how to think solution based yeah all you
know this is what's going on like let's
say you critique someone's like let's
say I'm a chef right and you you could
you critique my food and then you say
it's too salty you and I go [ __ ] you
it's not salty you're talking about you
don't know [ __ ] about food you know what
no no no no you didn't even go to
cooking school so you're irrelevant yeah
that's what ends up happening because
you pretty much brews this person in in
Soompi a lot of people they identify
themselves with the things that they do
so they don't know themselves right so
it's like let's say you said something
about their methods or actions are
incorrect mm-hmm which is [ __ ] valid
it's a business and even as friends you
should be able to say [ __ ] like that but
when they hear that this is what the
only thing that they hear is you're
wrong yeah so
that's all maturity though right like
it's it's like people that have an ego
they immediately want to protect that
they're not wrong they want to be right
and then nothing moves forward because
all they're doing is focusing on how
they're right so when you ask them okay
let's work on a solution
they're like blindsided like wait
solution no no no we don't need a
solution because I'm doing everything
right yeah
and that's it's like dude that to me is
a primitive mind like you're not gonna
get anywhere in life thinking like that
but they're unaware like there's like
they don't have the capacity in their
mind yet to understand that this is
pointless
like it's not gonna move anything
forward yeah all they want to do is feel
right so it's it's more like a feeling
preservation thing yeah that that that
feeling part was a stuff that I didn't
really understand because yeah when we
opened up a business there's there's a
lot of heart to it but you also can't
deny statistics and numbers right
because your results yeah right you want
to move past it you want to get results
you wanna you want to build something
you have a greater good mentality yeah
you have to understand how selfish most
people are and they're unaware like how
selfish they are I think some people
they care more about preserving their
self-image than profit or effectiveness
or and and once you realize that I think
like it's cut that swai it feels pretty
lonely like there's a lot of it that's
what the a lot of people are and that's
why they're not successful that's why
they're not be able to challenge
themselves to grow or anything nobody
recognizes that they all have this issue
you know and and and and it's like it's
pointless but it's I mean they don't
even know that this thing called the ego
exists yeah it's I wish I would've
talked to you about this before cuz it
was so [ __ ] weird cuz I didn't
understand I could not wrap my head
around it right so they like for me like
for example like when I added something
to to what we were creating and I didn't
do as well as I thought it would I said
take it off you know and I started
arguing about how good it is yeah even
if even if numbers and statistics show
that it doesn't sell
well yeah or if it's just a wasteful
item and we lose money on it
just yeah but it was my idea David I've
heard about it I really want this you
know it's like yeah it's not it's not
paying these employees it's not doing
anything you know it's just it's just
for you it's for you to feel good about
your product and like I'm talking about
beauty this [ __ ] this person
created like this dish and then they ate
it and they go it's amazing right and
and I ate it and I was like I don't like
it not good yeah right and they go what
do you mean you don't like it oh my god
okay geez I don't like it right and well
I think it tastes good let's leave it on
the menu to himself for [ __ ] didn't sell
for [ __ ] and then they will you gave it
a chance
yeah to see what the people voted and
then they didn't and wasn't the traveler
says I still gave it an opportunity and
even afterwards the I found out after I
took it off the menu they came back
through the other part that yeah they
were pretty pissed yeah they took it off
the menu and I'm like you were making us
lose money how can you be mad at me you
know yeah cuz it was like it's like you
said it was if they wanted to be right
and so right they're like well I know
what's good well clearly you don't you
[ __ ] sack of [ __ ] yes all of our
customer base hated it
yeah the partners didn't like it so what
the [ __ ] do you know maybe you should
stop smoking [ __ ] two [ __ ] packs
of cigarettes a day then you might have
tastebuds you select that yeah I should
tell my little salty is [ __ ] [ __ ] no
but what you're going through isn't
unique like yeah this is the number one
reason why I think people can't work in
groups people can't become more
successful people it's like no one
realizes the battle that they have is
within themselves because everybody
thinks it's everyone else mm-hmm and and
everyone's like oh you don't [ __ ]
know good food or you don't know good
film or whatever right like if the
problem comes when they identify who
they are with what they do it's like
what they do is not who they are
yeah but then if you if you realize like
how a lot of nerds right a lot of nerds
be like I'm so logical I'm so logical
everyone so so [ __ ] stupid but they
identify themselves with their
intelligence or
or their skills so that's why they have
to debate like a [ __ ] because
they don't want to be wrong because if
they're wrong then they're stupid and if
they're stupid then that that's not the
image of who they want to be
yeah they don't take they don't take it
as oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up my bad job they
don't feel apologetic for for me because
if I messed up I don't know if I should
feel this way but I'm like half [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up and I tried to say next time I
won't do this again and I'll see what
I'll do yeah to to to better this
company you're right I'm not just
thinking about myself I'm writing about
everybody else I'm thinking about these
kids that we hired on what you know they
have to get their bills paid and this
doesn't do well then they lose a [ __ ]
job exactly but I mean that's cuz you
grew up in a business yeah
that's cuz you think about like how
everyone is affected by your actions
most people can't even think their
because they've never been in a position
where they had to think that way so I
wish everybody had the opportunity to be
a boss or to own a business to hire
people because in most people's lives
you're dependent to somebody like we
grow up we're dependent to our parents
right and then like you know even the
school system when you're in college
you're dependent to your teachers they
they you know you get your grades that's
what you're valued as or whatever that's
the economy of the school right and then
you go into the workplace you're you're
given orders you work and then you want
to please your managers you want to do
good at your job so your service seeing
as an individual to a higher being like
like a thority figure right so a lot of
people go oh you know I don't know how
to become independent well yeah like
your whole life's been a dependent so
now you want to act and think
independent but it's it's difficult
because you've been trained all your
life to just please your superiors and
that's it but what about your peers what
about group work like even nobody's done
effective group work if you've done
group work in high school college or
whatever like everyone wants to slack
yeah right but that's why it's like I
get a lot of emails in and
in messages from from fans that are like
man me and my friends want to get
together and do this stuff but nobody's
motivated no one shows up on time how
many times have you heard that and we've
experienced that too a lot of [ __ ]
laziness
they can't just they can't get together
and do [ __ ] and do group work yeah and
be independent as in work as equals and
I think that transfers to the friendship
yeah like like it's difficult to have a
group of friends because a lot of people
are just all all over the place and just
worrying about themselves and not
knowing like yeah hey this is the this
is the [ __ ] effort we got to do to
have a dope as friendship that lasts a
lifetime yeah yeah but it's a lot to
think about man it's a lot to do and a
lot to think about but the cool thing is
if you work at it it's a guarantee that
you're gonna be better yeah yeah and I
guess just to wrap it all up
there's no set equation for this [ __ ]
and if you're a young person you're just
gonna have to get burned a couple of
times to figure it out and you know like
Joe said you'll develop that keen sense
of smell and you'll soon have n chili
but if you're going through a phase
right now where you feel like you have
to cut people out to better yourself
yeah then that's just a part of the
growing process or maybe you're a piece
of [ __ ] you're the cancer yeah and if
you are if you look back you're like oh
[ __ ] maybe I'm the one that's [ __ ] up
then change your [ __ ] ways yep
and you'll be good but yo that wraps
that episode no I like this thing man
you guys should just send a [ __ ]
yeah then we could help you guys out
we'll call this now still gonna be
called genius brain but remember guys
you guys can check us out on Spotify
stitch or all those audio
platform-specific to iTunes give us that
five stars leave in the comments below
if you're watching this on YouTube about
stuff that you guys want to talk about
bringing make personal stories if you
have something that you could be
specific about that we could help out
even more yeah so we will see you guys
next time and genius brain out bah bah